c'est ce qui est assez troublant c'est
que quand il parle pas c'est la
déconnexion et quand il parle c'est de
la communication
moi je suis un peu voyez circonspect
serre que ya pas de bons choix
donc là il fait le choix de s'exprimer
sur des plateaux très bien mais il
s'exprime régulièrement et à maintes
reprise il l'a déjà fait en irak mais là
il ya une semaine lors de ses
déplacements là il ya une intention
particulière coup sur coup il ya un
travail d'explication et de pédagogie
qui est cuite nécessaire c'est toujours
nécessaire d'expliquer les choses et de
faire de la pédagogie nous n'en avons
jamais fait ça c est ce que c'est du
moins une flat fin définitive de ce
qu'on a appelé laird jupitérienne où le
président n'avait pas trop envie de
parler dans les médias où il essayait de
travailler sur d'autres moyens
d'expression de devenir plus
présidentiel est ce que là finalement
c'est d'une façon de dire on a besoin de
cet exercice je sais pas si on a besoin
de cet exercice mais il a toujours eu
pour principe de s'exprimer sur des
supports différents et il l'a fait quand
il était candidat dans le cadre de
l'élection présentielle en allant sur
des supports assez inédit pour des
campagnes électorales disons
traditionnelle et donc je crois que il
veut maintenir cette relation qu'il a su
nouer avec les français à travers des
supports médiatiques qui sont très
différents entre 1 13 heures et puis un
exercice de deux heures avec deux
intervieweurs ce sont des formats
différents auprès d'audiences
différentes je crois avec ça qu'ils
souhaitent pouvoir honorer l'ensemble de
la campagne présidentielle si